[Music]
on this sunday night
the controversy over contact tracing
the plan to put the onus on those who
test positive
without contact tracing how are we going
to rein this in
as numbers spike in the two largest
provinces
the dangers of the flu season and covet
19.
i think we're all a little bit nervous
about it why doctors are asking
canadians
to get the shot donald trump's
health i was concerned for possible
rapid progression of the illness
when doctors think the u.s president can
get back on the campaign trail
and the green party's new leader makes
history
but faces many more challenges
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada's chief public health officer
has a stark warning
we're running out of time to prevent a
major resurgence of covet 19.
new numbers out of quebec show just how
dire this situation is
right now for the third day in a row the
province is reporting more than a
thousand new cases
in ontario the province's daily count is
566.
despite the spike in cases toronto
public health is changing the rules
around contact tracing
if you get infected in canada's largest
city you may have to break the news to
your friends and family
abigail beeman explains
in toronto cases are climbing so quickly
public health is now asking those who
test positive for covid19
to do their own contact tracing giving
instructions about how to notify close
contacts given what direction our
numbers are going well that's
that doesn't bode well does it there's
no change to the handling of high risk
situations like outbreaks in long-term
care and schools
i in fact think this is going to erode
public trust and confidence there'll be
an
extremely high level of variation with
that some people will be highly
responsible
some people i'm guessing won't do it at
all toronto is
cancelling or putting contact tracing on
hold
and ontario is telling us you know close
the testing centers let's
catch up on the backlog that's illusory
that isn't
that that does not give us the
information that we need to be able to
protect our communities
our health system is in crisis in the
nation's capital where the case count is
also high and
testing lines long public health
confirms contact tracing continues
but neither public health nor the
province nor the hospital that runs this
test site
would explain why it stayed open sunday
after ontario's premier said all sites
would be closed to walk-ins for two days
as they transitioned to appointments
booked online those images which we've
seen across ontario
really put public pressure on but if
it's only
online booking it's invisible there's no
way to know
how many people tried to log on and
couldn't how many people
tried to access a test and couldn't and
we don't know what happens to them after
that
in quebec case numbers topped a thousand
for the third day in a row
the country's chief medical officer of
health put out a statement sunday
focused on thanksgiving
dr teresa tam says we've got some
serious planning to do
though she didn't go as far as urging
cancellations as the prime minister
hinted at
last month it's all too likely we won't
be gathering for thanksgiving
tam recommends layering up on clothes
heading outdoors and keeping a picnic
table length apart from those not in
your bubble
and not to share food with them indoor
dinners will be safest if
small and select especially in the
country's hot spots
abigail beeman global news ottawa
we're at a very crucial juncture in the
pandemic cases are on the rise
and we're entering influenza season
experts are worried the health care
system could be overburdened with that
double threat
that's why they're encouraging canadians
to get the flu shot and as julia wong
explains provinces have been stocking up
the change of seasons brings with it
some uncertainty
canadians will deal not only with
influenza this fall
but kova 19 as well and then this year
we're facing basically two viruses
that are fairly similar in what they
look like at least in the initial stages
of disease
and we don't necessarily know what to
expect so i think we're all a little bit
nervous about it
similar symptoms mean the only way to
tell them apart is through testing
some provinces have already faced coven
19 testing challenges
long lines at assessment centers and
delays in getting results
another concern is the potential impact
both viruses could have on the health
care system
if you're really sick then you will you
will burden the hospital with a lot of
flu cases
as well as your on top of that you have
because there has been reopening
you would have cases of kobe 19 as well
medical experts emphasize it'll be
important to follow public health
measures like physical distancing
wearing a mask and sanitizing your hands
they say there's also another tangible
thing canadians can do
to keep themselves and others safe if
there's ever been a year for us to get
vaccinated for influenza
it absolutely is 20 20. this comes back
to doing our part
to try and reduce that burden on the
health care system
a recent survey done for the canadian
pharmacists association shows more
people intend to get the flu shot this
fall
57 percent this year compared to 45
percent
last year and 34 say they're more likely
to
because of coven 19. provinces meanwhile
are gearing up bc is building up its
testing capacity to deal with coven 19
and influenza for the first time alberta
is offering a high-dose flu vaccine to
all seniors in continuing care
and ontario is ordering more than five
million doses of the vaccine
seven hundred thousand more than last
year please
download the covet alert app please
get your flu shot this year it's
absolutely
critical all measures will be important
especially since health experts say it's
possible to contract both viruses
at the same time julia wong global news
the doctors treating u.s president
donald trump for kova 19 say
initially he was very ill but his health
is improving
wearing a mask trump took a short drive
outside the walter reed medical center
in maryland where he's being treated
to wave to supporters who gathered
outside his doctors now
say he could be released as early as
tomorrow that doesn't mean he'll be back
on the campaign trail right away
but that may bode well for his
democratic rival
as jennifer johnson explains a new poll
shows joe biden
is widening his lead u.s president
donald trump's doctors at walter reed
national military medical center
are now giving a more transparent
assessment of his condition
saying the president had multiple
episodes over the weekend that required
steroid therapy
typically given to people with more
severe cases of coven 19.
late friday morning when i returned to
the bedside president had a high fever
and his oxygen oxygen saturation was
transiently dipping
below 94 percent given these two
developments i was concerned for
possible rapid progression of the
illness
the white house was criticized for
sending mixed messages about the
president's condition saturday
dr conley denied he was trying to hide
anything his medical team now says
president trump's vital signs are good
and he is tolerating the steroid and the
experimental drug
remdezavir well if he continues to look
and feel as well as he does today our
hope is that we can plan for a discharge
as early as tomorrow
looking pale but presidential the
president released a video reassuring
americans
i feel much better now we're working
hard to get me all the way back i have
to be back
because we still have to make america
great again
the white house is defending how the
president and his staff rarely wear
masks or physically distance
at events and rallies some experts are
pointing to the supreme court nomination
ceremony last weekend
for judge amy coney barrett as the super
spreader for the virus
which has now infected the president
first lady and several others
it hasn't been cavalier at all we take
it very seriously it's why we give
everyone coming to rallies or to events
we give them a mask
we check their temperature the president
remains sidelined from the campaign
as a new nbc news wall street journal
poll shows democratic candidate joe
biden's lead widening
after last tuesday's debate 53-39
percent
the republican governor of ohio with the
debate was held
says the white house never informed him
the president or his aide hope hicks
tested positive for the virus they've
not reached out to me
they've not talked to me about it no
another member of the president's inner
circle who traveled with him to the
debate
special assistant nick luna has also
tested positive for covet 19
as the number of white house insiders
infected with the virus
continues to grow jennifer johnson
global news washington in a setback for
what was once the american epicenter
of the coven 19 pandemic new york city
is planning to once again
shut down some schools and non-essential
businesses
mayor bill de blasio says he wants to
rewind reopening
in nine neighborhoods all in the
boroughs of brooklyn and queens
these areas have a higher rate of
testing positive the closures could last
two to four weeks the plan still has to
be approved by the state's governor
british prime minister boris johnson
nearly died from kovitt 19.
now he says the u.k could see rolling
lockdowns for years
he made the comments as daily cases in
britain soared over 10 thousand for the
first time
since mass testing began in all canada
it's going to continue to be bumpy
through to christmas
it may have may even be bumpy beyond but
this is the only
way to do it it is still very possible
that there are bumpy bumpy months ahead
johnson did provide some hope he says
advice from leading scientists in the uk
suggests a vaccine could be available by
spring
japan's most famous fashion designer
kenzo takata has died from covid19
complications
the founder of the global kenzo brand
died today in a paris hospital
he retired from the fashion house in
1999 to pursue a career in art
but he remained one of the most
respected fixtures of the paris fashion
scene
kenzo takata was 81.
a major infrastructure project cleared a
significant hurdle and it could lead to
more exports from canada's oil patch
the alaska to alberta railway would
start in the heart of the oil sands and
serve as a transportation corridor
to anchorage and then on to asia but as
michael couture reports
a number of steps remain before the
project becomes a reality
there could soon be another way of
getting canadian oil to market
the proposed project is called the
alaska to alberta railway and would
stretch
more than 2500 kilometers from fort
mcmurray
to the port in anchorage it's still in
the planning stages but the company is
already talking about economic benefits
for northern canada
this is going to bring 18 000 plus jobs
during construction
it's also being touted as a lifeline for
other supplies to flow faster to
northern communities
rail is is capable of supporting
green forestry products you look along
that line there's all sorts of mining
activities
the project was just given a
presidential permit to go ahead but the
issue
could be on this side of the border the
liberal government had been criticized
by the courts for not
properly consulting indigenous
communities on the trans mountain
pipeline project
leading to delays while the prime
minister points out no
proposal has been submitted for this
rail line
trudeau says proper consultation is the
foundation of bill c-69
seeing off the bat whether there is a
potential for a project
before the proponent goes too far down
the road and
invests too much money in it in
something that is unlikely to pass
or find out early that perhaps there is
a different approach that is better
the opposition disagrees we've seen
investment here in alberta and across
the energy sector
flee in what is probably approaching the
billions of dollars since this
government came into place so
i have no faith that bill c-69 will
expedite this project still the calgary
mp says
this fledgling project is providing hope
in the oil sector
as an alternative to the trans mountain
pipeline the pipelines
and the rail have the ability to
economically move the product to
tidewater
so they can they can complement each
other and yes
at the fringes they'll compete with each
other it all depends on future demand of
petroleum products and how quickly or
even if
the rail line can get on track michael
couture global news ottawa
california has set a new wildfire record
this year more than 1.6 million hectares
of land have been scorched
that's the most in a single year ever to
put that into context that's nearly
three times the size of prince edward
island
the previous record was set two years
ago all of this year's destruction has
basically happened since mid-august
right now there are 23 major wildfires
burning across the state
the fires have killed at least 31 people
and destroyed nearly
9 000 structures including homes and
wineries
coming up the impact of coven 19 on the
mental health
of canadians
tonight a worrying picture is emerging
on the impact of the pandemic on our
mental health
new research shows levels of anxiety and
depression
are up as cases rise ross lord dives
into the statistics and looks at how
people in one province
have taken a particularly hard hit in
this stressful year
now that the pandemic has become a way
of life in canada there's growing
evidence of its impact
in a new survey of four thousand
canadians conducted by mental health
researchers
our goal was to really try to get a
sense of how are people doing
with dealing with covet in terms of
anxiety depression and other mental
health needs
among their findings one in five
canadians have been diagnosed with
anxiety or depression
anxiety levels have quadrupled since the
pandemic started
and they remain four times higher than
before the outbreak
high levels of anxiety are most
prominent in ontario
newfoundland and labrador and in nova
scotia
the survey found high levels of
depression are also most prominent in
nova scotia
a surprise when you consider the virus
has been almost non-existent in the
province for months
researchers say fear of the virus among
nova scotia's older population helps
explain their findings
along with stress from another source we
had what was the largest mass shooting
in canadian history
the port of peak mass shooting occurring
during
lockdown the gunman's partner told
police he was paranoid about the
[Music]
pandemic
among other findings things that helped
people cope like so-called online
kitchen parties
have worn off eight months into the
pandemic what worked for them in the
beginning
didn't isn't perceived as working
anymore even the summertime weather
didn't lower the levels of anxiety and
depression
i think it really doesn't bode well for
the second wave we're now experiencing
and once winter starts to hit and people
are socially isolating even more
the fear of course is that people's
mental health will
deteriorate even more the study says
covet 19 has shown a light on
shoddy mental health resources that
leave people on waiting lists to access
support
the good news compared to an earlier
survey from april
this one shows more canadians are
confident they'll bounce back
suggesting those who can are ready to
tough it out until conditions improve
ross lord global news
still ahead the challenge is facing the
green party's new leader
in the time of covet
[Music]
you're watching global national
the next leader of the green party
of canada enemy paul
after a year-long race the green party
has a new leader
anime paul a lawyer has made history by
becoming the first
elected black leader of a major federal
party in canada
she replaces elizabeth may who was the
face of the party
for 14 years and joining me now is the
new leader of the green party anime paul
first of all congratulations but as you
know
there is so much to do your party
managed to get three seats in the house
of commons in the last election and the
pundits
always said the greens were the ones to
watch and yet your party hasn't been
able to get the traction that is
necessary
to hold some kind of balance of power
what will you do differently from
elizabeth may
well first let's keep in mind that this
isn't
an elizabeth may issue this is really
something that is structural in our
political system
uh the way that things are designed we
give people many more reasons to vote
against
a party than for a party and we know
that that's what happens in the last
election
where over a third of people voted uh
strategically
i think that uh this pandemic and all of
the
the critical and urgent situations
associated with it
that would have been better served by
our policies
has given us a new case that we can make
to people in canada
a big part of your party is about
climate change the ndp and the liberals
have had their own green plans but
all of that is overshadowed by the
pandemic so how can you bring the center
piece of your party's existence
back to the forefront the center piece
of our party's existence in fact
is our people and the needs of people
in canada we need emergency we need
urgent benefits
that we need to create structural
changes so that this
situation never happens again and that
we're more resilient
and we've been talking about those
things forever we have been leading on
social policy
and this moment in time has really
demonstrated how incredibly important
our social policies are
you're running in toronto center's
by-election that's bill morneau's old
riding how confident are you that you
can win that seat and if you don't win
the by-election
how will you manage to lead outside of
parliament
well i did made the decision to run in
this by-election
well before the vote on the next leader
of the party
because my roots are very deep in the
writing it's a writing that i was born
in and my mother taught in
my grandmother worked as a frontline
worker in the hospitals inn
and it's a writing that has been
profoundly neglected
by candidate after candidate parachuted
in
by the liberals and so i ran because i
believe that people in toronto center
deserve real representation
i ran because i believe that enough is
enough and so
i hope that toronto center residents
will agree with me
and they have every reason to
particularly in the midst of this
pandemic
and i have become a pro on how to
campaign in in a pandemic
and i'm looking forward to applying all
of those skills
to uh to make our case to canadians over
the coming months
anime paul thank you for your time and
once again congratulations
thank you so very much take care up next
the young royals and their wild
questions for sir david
there's canadian pride at the london
marathon brent lakitas has won the men's
elite wheelchair race
the quebec native raced with his own
specially designed wheelchair crossing
the finish line in one hour
46 minutes and four seconds this is his
first major marathon victory
lakitas has seven paralympic medals
under his belt
as well as 11 world track titles
the children of the duke and duchess of
cambridge got the chance to quiz
david attenborough about nature prince
george princess starlet
and prince louis brought their wildlife
curiosities straight to the acclaimed
naturalist and broadcaster
it's rare to hear the young royal speak
and george cut to the chase
hello david attenborough what animal do
you think will become extinct
next well let's hope there won't be any
because there are lots of things we can
do when animals are reduced to
and danger of extinction we can protect
them
hello you gave your national girl i like
spiders do you like spiders too
i love spiders i'm so glad you like them
i think they're wonderful things why is
it the people so
frightened of them i think it's because
they've actually got eight legs
the virtual chat is part of a campaign
to promote attenborough's
new documentary adorable and that is
global national for this sunday i'm
robin gill
tonight your canada is the brant street
pier in burlington ontario we would love
to see your corner of this country so
please
send your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen is
back tomorrow good night
[Music]
you